[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein herz auf das rezept
und zwar werden wir eine lex zog in die
pfanne machen
wir haben jetzt gerade heute morgen
gestartet mit dem videodreh und ich habe
gerade eine torte im backofen noch steht
noch da noch 25 minuten und ich habe ja
kommen wir überbrücken jetzt die zeit
und werden jetzt etwas herzhaftes kochen
das machen wir öfters dann haben wir
nämlich auch noch süßes am tag und was
herzhaftes und zur mittagszeit kann man
dann alle zusammen essen genau wenn
nicht zwei trocken am tag macht man ja
sie haben richtig große aber jetzt
vermutlich kurz richtig humor willkommen
also länger und gar nicht geplant ist
wie gar nicht geplant deswegen habe
einfach den kühlschrank aufgemacht
gestern habe ich zwei krimis aus dem
garten mitgenommen dann hatte ich noch
lachsfilet im gefrierfach und hab
gedacht komm jetzt mache war einfach
eine lachs zucchini pfanne mit nudeln
richtig lecker und ich zeige euch jetzt
auch mal die zutaten für das rezept
brauche ich 500 gramm lachsfilet das ist
jetzt wirst lachs und war tief gefroren
ich hab's auftauen lassen sechs
esslöffel olivenöl eine zwiebel zwei
teenies ein paar cocktailtomaten eine
unbehandelte zitrone 50 gramm sahne 175
g frischkäse im doppel rahmen stufe salz
und pfeffer ein bisschen chili ein paar
basilikumblätter und 500 gramm nudeln
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal den fisch
und es auch darum geht auch super
schnell ich legte es einfach immer in
wasser die sind ja in so einer folie
eingeschweißt und dann ist es wirklich
super schnell weil sie den abstand dort
tee kaffee schnaps in richtung vor allem
hat man dann immer was auf vorrat den
schneide ich jetzt in mundgerechte
stücke und kann in der zwischenzeit auch
schon mal das olivenöl in der pfanne
heiß werden lassen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die lachsfilet stücke hier
in die heiße pfanne und ich kann jetzt
auch schon mal das nudelwasser zum
kochen bringen
denn dass es ein superschnelles rezept
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die zwiebel klein wirken die
zucchini die werde ich vierteln und dann
einfach fein hobeln und die tomaten noch
halbieren
[Musik]
den fisch habe ich jetzt raus genommen
jetzt kommen die zwiebelwürfel in den
topf und falls kein öl mehr drinnen ist
dann solltet ihr einfach noch mal zwei
bis drei esslöffel öl zufügen und die
zwiebeln werden jetzt muss bei höchster
stufe sondern bei mittel hoher hitze
gegangen
[Musik]
sobald die zwiebeln glasig sind kommen
jetzt die zucchini stücke mit rein und
weiß jetzt ein bisschen anders machen
wollte als ich dann wartet am besten den
lachs in einer beschichteten pfanne ist
so bleibt mir nämlich am topfboden nicht
geben weil wir hier ziemlich und jetzt
ein bisschen was ist jetzt nicht weiter
schlimm
ich werde jetzt die zuglinie einfach 345
minuten mitbraten und in der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal gelogen
abkochen
das mache ich jetzt hier drücken da habe
ich schon das wasser zum kochen gebracht
habe auch schon bald mit drinnen und die
nudeln kommen jetzt hier rein und werden
nach packungsanleitung drin gab es vor
das liegt auch schon richtig gehen
nächste richtig gut
das wird richtig lecker und ich kann so
lange noch die tomaten halbieren oder
ich glaube ich werde sogar vierter
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich noch den fisch käse mit
dazu dann auch die sahne und damit es
ganz anders schöne soße wird auch ein
bisschen nudelwasser ihr könnt aber zum
beispiel auch ein bisschen weißwein dazu
geben
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich das hier nämlich
aufkochen lassen und dann ein bisschen
einkochen das ganze natürlich mit salz
und pfeffer würzen
die tomaten kommen dann erst ganz zum
schluss mit rein und dann muss ich jetzt
im prinzip nur noch basilikum fein
hacken
die zitronenschale kommt auch zum
schluss rein und jetzt machen bevor
sauber
[Musik]
jetzt da sich die soße hier nochmal kurz
aufkochen und gebe es hier noch die
tomaten und basilikum mit rein ein
plätzchen was ich für dich übrig und
chili mit rein also ein bisschen samir
und ella sind heute bei oma und daher
kümmern bis zum bachelor machen und dann
ein bisschen zitronenschalen april mit
hand wieder wo kraft geholt hat ihren
wir die kommt auf see vom atomkraftwerk
ist ja ich glaube da ist er aufgewachsen
sei und deswegen jetzt immer im prinzip
schon fertigkeit des jahres verstorben
insgesamt vielleicht schon gebrauchen
wenn wir das hergestellte 20 minuten
aber ohne filmen auf jeden fall nur eine
viertelstunde jetzt noch den fisch mit
rein
das ganze kann man natürlich auch mit
hühnchen zum beispiel machen und
schmeckt auch sehr lecker vor dass ich
das jetzt einfach frisch sack werde ich
nicht fünf stunden also mit 50 sogar
schon zwei jahren für seine ist ich bin
ja so ein fan davon also die nudeln habe
ich schon abgeschüttelt und ich bin
entfernt davon nudeln direkt mit in die
soße
[Musik]
ich glaube den den jugendtreff gerade
auch überall dass die jungs und mädels
für jungs und mädels läuft das wasser im
mund zusammen und mir auch und mein
magen ob das hat so ein tiefes loch und
jetzt zum schluss müssen natürlich noch
ich glaube man hat sogar morgen gehört
jetzt zum schluss ist dann natürlich
noch mit salz und pfeffer abschmecken
vielleicht ein bisschen chili rein aber
ich denke ich wirklich musik ihm heraus
hier im keller bestimmt viel geld hin so
schöpfkelle wo ich habe aber nicht
abgeschmeckt ob salz und er verpasst
aber du sagst aber ich nehme immer das
sieht immer so aus als würde ich zu viel
nehmen genau lässt grüßen die kanzlerin
ist vom salon danke vollkommen und ein
organist zerdrückt
platz probier mal ganz schön gemacht
vorgestellt hatte sagt ja gebraucht und
jetzt probiere ich okay ich habe zwei
wellen bank modeln genommen ihr könnt
natürlich auch tage da zählen neben oder
spaghetti ich zähle dann mache ich den
abschluss heute sehr kurz denn wir haben
alle sehr sehr hunger und ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim backen
das findet ihr auch zu lesen dass
blog.de und ja wir sehen das ist nicht
unbedingt nachmachen und jetzt wollte
ich auch in seiner vernichtung und für
ein paar samt alle essen
[Musik]